[Music]
it's my mom yeah it's just us you and us
who you were in the bar with my name's
not lost
where did you see the lady wasn't one
lady the female jogger it was severely
beaten and raped every black male who's
in the park last night is a suspect I
need all of them what's going on with my
son your son was involved in the rape in
Central Park they saw you rape the lady
and see a lady or hit anyone I don't see
any lady Kevin I want to see my son
right now right now
whatever they said I did
nothing these Boise State matches the
central facts of a crime all we need is
for one to tie this whole thing together
these tapes are not as clean as the
state would have you believe there is
injustice happening here there is not
one shred of evidence the frenzy of
these teenagers ripping off her we are
innocent of these crass guilty
looks like this what other way they ever
do us ahead of those trailers
parents footsteps and become closer and
closer
that's me coming from the wall
they said if I went along with it that
are gone and that's all I wanted the
police would do anything with us they
would lock us up it would kill us
this is my life
I don't think we should admit to
something that we didn't do
okay you keep fighting
[Music]